jack dorsey and michael saylor recently
sat down to talk about bitcoin one of
the questions that michael saylor had
was how jack thinks about bitcoin trust
and transparency here is jack's own
words as to how he thinks about this
digital decentralized asset you see
bitcoin lightning as like universal
monetary protocol yeah 100 i mean it and
and probably beyond that i mean
there was a time early in bitcoin's
history when the there was less of a
focus on on on bitcoin as a currency
aspect and just as that transport and
more on the on blockchain technology
blockchain
technology is
amazing but the network's power is what
people do with it and the use cases and
in the use case
for the internet to have something like
this is i think as fundamental as tcp or
http
um sm np which is a mail uh protocol so
these these open protocols create
companies they create uh projects they
they create entirely new cultural and
societal shifts um that i think
ultimately lead to more trust and more
transparency as time goes on and
diminishment of all these barriers and
boundaries that we've erected
i think this is such a good point by
jack here in the sense that there are
other protocols that are open source
that other people have been able to
build whether they're products companies
or other projects on top of that's
exactly what's happening with bitcoin
the second you get an open monetary
protocol that anyone can send value to
anyone else in the world without asking
permission of any middleman any third
party or any rent seeker you can only
begin to imagine today 12 13 years into
the life of bitcoin that we have seen
just a sliver of what will be possible
the second that you reduce the friction
and you increase the ability for people
to send that economic value on an open
system every single person will be
connected will be able to send value and
the number of companies the number of
projects and the number of interfaces
that will be built on top we haven't
seen anything yet jack dorsey
understands this michael saylor
understands this and eventually everyone
in the world will get it as well